Who Would You cast to play characters
who've never even appeared in the movies
before and which actor proved just sassy
enough that he may even make a better
Harry than Daniel Radcliffe the boy who
lived has some pretty big shoes to fill
he's gotta be heroic but we'd love to
see a sassier side to Harry come out too
considering he's a lot sassier in the
books than Daniel Radcliffe came across
in the movies especially against a
certain potions teacher will be coming
up on this list next for that we're
looking at Archie Yates they don't even
know I'm here not only does he look the
part but his role as rebellious 10 year
old Max Mercer in home sweet home alone
proves that he has what it takes to make
a great boy wizard